I'm right there breaking tonight the
National Rifle Association says
President Trump has told its top
official universal background checks for
potential gun purchasers are off the
table that news coming shortly after the
president held court on a wide array of
topics including gun control chief White
House correspondent John Roberts is that
that P spray turned impromptu press
conference he joins us from the North
law good evening John it was almost a
full-blown press conference Brett we
were in the Oval Office for about a half
an hour's time one of the questions I
had for the president he seemed to back
off on his earlier support following the
El Paso and Dayton shootings for
enhanced background checks perhaps not
universal background checks but at least
closing some loopholes the president
leaving Bedminster New Jersey over the
weekend appeared to back off on that a
little bit and now we learn from NRA
sources that the president called Wayne
LaPierre this afternoon and told him
that universal background checks are off
the table without mentioning background
checks when lapidaire tweeted quote I
spoke to the president today we
discussed the best ways to prevent these
types of tragedies president Trump is a
strong Second Amendment president and
supports our right to keep and bear arms